sid meier's civilization beyond Earth is
your chance to create the future of
humanity after emerging from the global
Dark Age known as the great mistake the
human race struggles to survive on earth
the redeveloped Nations focus on finding
a new home on a new planet now your
leadership is needed to colonize these
alien worlds amass mighty armies and
make contact with new life-forms sid
meier's civilization beyond Earth is a
game of discovery and creation all
fueled by your sage decisions this new
entry into the award-winning
civilization series from Firaxis will
feel familiar to longtime players while
some all new features may seem a little
alien the unexpected worlds of beyond
Earth will present you with surprising
challenges from your first turn to your
final victory
your mission begins by selecting a
sponsor assembling a spacecraft choosing
cargo and colonists and launching into
the unknown even these early decisions
will be vital to your long-term survival
and victory there are eight expedition
sponsors to choose from each with his
own cultural identity and distinct
advantages once you make planetfall
carefully evaluate the resources
available in your landing area and
settle in this will be your capital from
which you can chart a course for
development
you must prioritize between food
production culture science and energy
venture out and scout this unfamiliar
world setting up new outposts to expand
your empire early it won't be long
before other colonies begin to pop up
push back the fog of war to reveal lush
arid and fungal biomes full of alien
terrain and creatures but beware of
dangers like the poisonous miasma which
can be harmful to any unit that ends its
term within it set up research
technologies and deploy satellites to
support your expansion the orbital layer
offers many strategic capabilities
satellites will eventually fall out of
orbit so be prepared to send explorers
out to survey these crash sites as an
ambassador for the human race
your primary consideration is its
well-being there are a variety of
factors that will affect your
civilizations health be mindful of them
for increased production and faster
growth
this is an alien world attack at your
own risk but know that there are always
peaceful alternatives initially you'll
want to send units out to chart your
surroundings locate resource pods and
undertake expeditions each Explorer
carries a limited number of expedition
modules which are used to uncover
artifacts or recover resources from
fallen satellites as you seek out wild
zones you may stomp out alien nests to
harvest their resources these rich areas
are a great place to start a city but
these ecosystems have natural defenses
for instance killing smaller enemies
like wolf beetles will eventually raise
the ire of larger seed worms and Krakens
the temperament of the indigenous life
forms is represented by their icon color
identifying the right time to expand
outward is a critical skill after
research and pioneering you can create
colonists who will venture out to build
outposts after a set number of turns an
outpost will transform into a city at
this point the city becomes useful and
productive humanity must adapt to
survive your civilizations philosophy
for adaptation is known as an affinity
there are three affinities to choose
from
harmony supremacy and purity these
affinities affect everything from
changing how your buildings and units
function to revealing unique resources
colonies that follow the Harmony
affinity focus on transforming humanity
through gene splicing and genetic
modification harmony leaders seek
coexistence with the aliens and the
native terrain advanced harmony colonies
can produce their own versions of native
alien life
and derive healing agents from the
planet itself supremacy colonies believe
humans can settle any world through
nanotechnology augmentation and
cybernetics supremacy leaders adopt a
more robotic appearance and advanced
units include unmanned drones and combat
robots
purity colonies believe that this new
world should be adapted to humanity's
way of life
purity focuses on the preservation and
glorification of human history and
physiology these civilizations rely on
sophisticated exosuits and vehicles to
survive and conquer each affinity
progresses through quests decisions and
the development of new technology higher
affinity levels read more powerful
bonuses and greater access to unique
wonders that can be critical to victory
affinities are entirely situational and
not preset based on faction leader
personalities so each game is a
completely different experience ripe for
experimentation
sid meier's civilization beyond Earth
breaks the conventions of linear
development constantly pushing you into
an uncertain future with experimental
technology the tech web is where all
your skills and research live each
primary tech has a few associated
specialized Tech's attached to it and
you don't have to move in one set path
to unlock new Tech's you'll start in the
center of the web with familiar
technology nearby and exotic elements at
the fringes choose carefully you won't
be able to unlock the entire web in one
game advance your units by unlocking new
technologies but keep in mind they cost
resources to maintain keep them alive
and they can be a key asset throughout
your game
your new civilization will really begin
to take shape as your colony expands
across the land sea and skies tact and
diplomacy trade and alliances will give
you a great advantage over your
neighbors for the first time you have
the ability to trade and save favours
from other leaders you can also operate
from the shadows with a spy agency
deploying your agents on covert ops
across the planet researching pioneering
will also allow for the creation of
trade routes and convoys between cities
in order to increase resources and
energy you can also set up trade between
independent specialized stations
stations provide powerful yields that
get more lucrative the longer you trade
with them but they must be cultivated
and sheltered as you advance your
technology you will also begin to
encounter quest chains quests reveal
more about your society on a day to day
personal level and provide bonuses for
your actions and decisions that can
affect affinity
colonisation and development are
exciting but always keep your end game
in sight and be prepared to shift with
the climate of the game there are five
possible ways to win in civilization
beyond Earth the purity affinity wins
the game by constructing the Exodus game
connecting this new planet to earth they
bring refugees out from earth to a new
home in the promised land victory the
Harmony victory constructs the mind
flower which merges the consciousness of
all living creatures with the latent
sentient of the planet in the
transcendence victory the supremacy
affinity also returns to earth in the
emancipation victory but they send a
peacekeeping force back to earth as they
bring their technological enlightenment
to those on the original homeworld the
remaining two victories do not rely on
any one affinity in the contact victory
you will discover a mysterious signal
decode it and build a beacon to attract
a benevolent advanced alien race and
serve as ambassadors for Humanity in the
domination victory you conquer your
opponents and capture their capitals
while keeping your original capital
becoming the unquestioned ruler of the
planet regardless of which path to
victory you choose you will need to be
aware of your own strengths and how your
opponents might be trying to win for
themselves
let me give you a new speaker it's time
to leave behind the civilisations of old
and venture forth across the endless
void of space to seek out a new way of
life for Humanity beyond Earth the
future is but one more turn away
you